[Musique]
ils sont fous de leurs chien et n'ont
plus peur de le montrer mieux certains
propriétaires ne s'embarrassent plus du
ridicule et projettent sur leurs
compagnons leurs envies de mode et de
fantaisie un marché où l'on trouve pmel
parfum vêtements et accessoires de luxe
etorg leur eniron Éric de
l'agneau Marie et Christian mèent une
grande histoire d'amour depuis un an et
demi avec
pous tantôt tricot tantôt sauvage
pimous est gâté du chien dans la
garde-robe et du strass dans les
oreilles je pense que jamais personne n
vu un chien qui dit je voudra col je vra
ce manteau donc finalement fa remettre
les choses à leur place c'est le maître
qui joue à la poupée qui se fait
plaisir et coussin
Griff colier bijoux et produit
cosmétique depuis un an la mode et le
design s'empar du marché 8 millions de
chiens en France et leur maître qui
dépend sans compter du manteau de grand
couturier au parfum le nouveau filon
commercial c'est l'accessoire pour chien
branchés on fait les des petits
panierons comme ça qu'ils adorent parce
que ça leur rappelle quand il était leur
mère adore la fausse fourure les chiens
des niches qui sont entièrement
démontable comptez 150 € minimum pour
une niche et dans le panier de cette
chef d'entreprise il y a aussi des
vêtements t-shirt pour l'été manteau en
tweed pour l'hiver c'est un peu grâce à
Toto que la collection a vu le
jour quelque part on provoque c'est la
provocation et donc ça marche ou ça
marche pas et là bon ça ça marche ça
séduit des des clients donc Paris est un
peu gagné comme ça même habillé le chien
reste un animal à poil rendez-vous chez
la styliste deux à trois fois plus cher
qu'un toilettage classique toute la
différence c'est l'inspiration moi je
travaille un peu comme si je peignais
comme un tableau c'est-à-dire je sais
pas du tout quand je commence mon chien
comment je vais le réaliser et
d'ailleurs tout le monde ici réalise les
mêmes choses c'està-dire on regarde le
chien et puis c'est millimèt par
millimètre centimèt par centimètre le
petit poil qui va dépasser chaque année
les Français dépensent près d'un
milliard et demi d'euros pour leur chien
le marché ne laisse personne indifférent
SAF peut-être les principaux
intéressés